(crowd clapping)
It's good to be back,
it's good to be back.
First of all,
I gotta mention you...
We'll talk about,
you were an intern here at the show?
I was an intern,
yeah.
The cage was right over there.
(host laughs)
Five years ago,
you were.
And this is what happens when
people intern on our show,
they all become-
That's what happens.
Get your applications in.
Yeah.
(tongue clicking)
Thanks a lot.
Yeah, yeah. The money's good
when you were an intern?
It is.
Did you have a good time
when you were an intern
on this show?
I had a blast.
My job is actually to just
hang out backstage with you
just before you went on.
And you'd run through
some monologue jokes.
They always have a...
it's funny.
We always have a few interns back there
just to let them see what,
how it goes.
Yeah,
exactly.
And there was a one monologue
joke that I remember so well,
and you were extremely funny,
but the joke was Pat Buchanan
had his kidney stones removed
last week.
And he knew about them for a while,
but he just found out that the
two kidney stones were gay.
(host laughing)
(crowd laughing)
I thought that was the
funniest thing I'd ever seen.
So I started laughing and laughing.
And you were like,
"Do you think that's funny?"
And I said,
"Yeah".
And you were like,
"No,
you don't".
All you kids do is go home and smoke pot
and listen to Pearl jam.
(crowd Laughing)
I was like "yeah".
If that's what he thinks
of us we are okay.
Get out of my lawn, those are my apples.
(crowd laughing)
You didn't know that I'm 64 years old.
Oh yeah,
that's me.
That's me- Hey that lawn.
That's a beautiful lawn back there.
It's beautiful back there.
It is,
it really is.
It's very nice. Let's
talk about this is...
First of all,
we're all very happy for you.
You've done so well and I
think one of the hardest parts
of your job now in the office
is you work with Mr. Curral.
And he's such a funny guy,
We've had him here on the show a bunch...
But he's so funny.
How do you not laugh when
you're working with him?
Cause you have to say stay straight.
Yeah,
the simple answer to that is you don't.
You break all the time.
He's nothing without writers, but yeah.
Once he gets going,
once he gets going
he actually...
The sad thing is,
now that we're in our second season,
he knows exactly how to get us laughing
Right.
And so he does this thing where every time
he gets slightly emotional,
I just lose it.
And so there was this one
scene where he asked me
to help him and I didn't
really want to help him.
And he says,
"I don't know.
I really have it tough.
And you know everybody in this office,
you think Santa has it
tough, but Santa has elves.
Okay".
(crowd laughing)
And no one is elving me.
And I think I was under
the desk at that point then
(host laughing)
(indistinct)?
Yeah.
That would be...
And so you get to also.
There's some adlibbing,
obviously going on,
He does.
You just hold on for dear
life and try not to laugh.
Now we actually,
we come from a similar,
pretty much the same place.
I'm from Brooklyn.
You're from Newton Massachusetts?
I am from Newton Mass.
So we're like grew up.
(crowd shouting)
They're not from there,
they just wanna listen to their applause.
That's true.
Yeah,
well I'm from right around you.
I've actually seen you walking
your dog on the holidays.
What?
Oh,
yeah.
You see me walk.
Were you like following
me in some pervy way?
(crowd laughing)
There He is,
yeah.
(interviewee smiling)
No,
I would never stop you because
you looked like you were
having such a good time
and I didn't want you to start running.
Like I'm like "Cohen".
Was I alone?
No, you're with your dog, Hudson.
(crowd laughing)
How do you know my dog's name?"
He's six and a half years
old and he like pedigree dog.
Probably at 6:15 PM.
Yeah.
This is all true.
Everything you've said.
That's very eerie,
dude.
Do you go back to Massachusetts much?
I do.
I go back a lot.
I was actually just
there a couple days ago.
I just had a niece and,
so no applause?
(crowd shouting)
To hell with babies.
That was weird.
Isn't that weird they've
plotted the Newton mass.
He said," I just had a niece".
"Nothing from us, bring up Newton again".
(crowd laughing)
Exactly.
So I was back there and I was
at South station looking at
the board that takes over to
tell you what track you're on
and some guy,
And this is great because
Boston always keeps you humble.
I mean,
this guy was a just great
stereotypical, Boston guy.
And he says, "John, John from the office"
and I go,
"Yeah".
And he's like,
"Love the show,
funniest show on television".
And I was like,'
"Oh, thank you so much".
And I was about to go over and say,
thank you for what?
And he's like,
"Yeah. Okay. Take care.
I almost missed my train,
take care,
buddy.
All right,
that's enough.
Easy there,
stalker.
Weirdo.
That is so true because,
when I go back,
they always sort of let you know,
you had nail.
Don't get too big on yourself.
Yeah.
I went,
I remembered flying into Logan Airport,
not too long ago.
It was like a year ago.
And I literally just walked
out of the airport and just got
like to within,
I wasn't even going to get
in the cab lines because
my brother was picking me up.
But I walked out of the
airport and I just sort of was
walking around.
And you just walk out and
I got to near the front of
the cab line and this guy's like,
" Hey, there TV star get
in the back of the line"
(crowd laughing).
I didn't know that was my dad.
Yeah.
That was probably,
yeah.
He said,
"How's your dog Hudson".
(crowd laughing)
Oh man,
They let you know.